Come on, I don't have all night.
Ahh! What the hell are you smoking in here?
Smoking? Oh-ho, none of that, my good officer.
I believe the term you are looking for is:
conjuring!
Cut the shit -- and give me your license and
registration.
Oh dear! Is there something we've done wrong,
traversing this dark avenue of the night?
You were going 70 on a side street and by
the looks of things, you've got a lot else
going on.
Were we? Or was that simply, an *illusion*?
Are you going to give me your license and
registration, or amI going to give you a *citation*?
Very well. Very well, sir.
Aha! Here you are.
Magician's License? I don't have time--
Look again.
Cute. How about your registration.
For that trick I'll need the help of my lovely:
assistant.
OK, on account of your speed and the smoke,
I'm going to have to give you a sobriety test.
Please step out of the car.
An escape act!
Hey! Hey!
What the?
Alright, keep your eyes on the pen.
I've had enough of this.
You have the right to remain silent. Anything
you say can and will be used against you in
a court of law.
You have the right to an attorney. If you
can't afford one, one will be assigned to
you.
OK! I'm sorry! I'm sorry!
Look, surely two gentlemen such as ourselves
can work out an agreement here.
Don't take this the wrong way, but the transvestite
will do... anything!
Ma'am... or... sir, get out of the vehicle.
Keep your hands where I can see them.
What is all this shit?
We have a gig tomorrow.
Not anymore you don't.
Ugh.
Hey!
Shazam! What do you think of that?
Freeze!
What the hell?
Looking for this?
Step right up and see the show of a lifetime!
You! That's right can experience the greatest
wonders of our world, right from where you
stand.
Come watch us conjure up a little fun!
Your chance is now! It's a night that you'll
never forget!
Look at this guy!
Are you OK man?
What happened? Where are they?
We're right here man, we're right here!
You had that smoke in your face, and you fell,
and you wiped OUT man, you wiped OUT.
So gone.
My shift is over, and I have a massive headache,
so I'm going to let you two go. Just don't
let me catch you out here again.
That's awesome!
Alright!
Right on!
Yeah!